we're just going to bring you these uh
live and exclusive pictures here from
inside
the presidential palace
what you are looking at right now
is taliban fighters
inside the presidential palace this is
these pictures exclusive on al jazeera
that we've been watching them for a few
moments now milling around the the lush
environs of the presidential palace
we're not sure if they're making an
announcement yet but the the camera has
been trailing those fighters as they
make their way through the halls of the
afghan presidential
palace wandering up through the building
uh decta in its finery of course this
after the afghan president
uh fled
the capital
that's them taking their way through uh
the
marbled halls of the presidential uh
palace
showing the that's our um it's one of
our arabic colleagues who is basically
showing uh doing a quick show-and-tell
around uh the presidential palace where
of course
many taliban fighters are accompanying
him
with weapons slung over their arms a
very grand building a building of course
that that played host to many
dignitaries and of course where the
afghan presidents
was uh
the one-time ruler of the lands
i'm not entirely sure which desk they
are sitting behind but there it's almost
like a family photo shots of the taliban
fighters
sitting behind a very grand desk
in the middle of the presidential palace
let's uh let's bring in our
correspondent in kabul rob mcbride he's
at the al jazeera bureau when we get a
translation of course we'll try and
bring that up but uh for now rob we're
just showing our
uh viewers these uh fairly stunning uh
exclusive pictures i also have to add
from al jazeera of taliban fighters
placing their guns on the desks sitting
behind the desk
of we assume that is the desk of the the
afghan president a fairly stunning
turnaround
of events in kabul uh you started the
day
uh certainly with the the news that the
taliban fighters were surrounding the
city
now they're inside the presidential
palace
absolutely i mean this has been a
remarkable
day of fast-changing events and it uh
continues into uh this uh sunday evening
uh
yes we saw earlier on this sunday
evening in fact still images of taliban
fighters inside the palace now we have
moving images and we also have been
seeing images of taliban fighters
outside the palace posing for selfies
with uh their fellow fighters etc so
very much uh this has been a day that
yes began uh with the encirclements the
siege of uh kabul uh pulling the the
noose tighter if you like around the
city the culmination of course of uh
weeks of gains by the taliban across
afghanistan taking province after
province gradually forces falling back
as provinces fell
and all of the focus all of the
attention all of this great momentum
that the taliban built up uh then being
focused uh and directed towards kabul
itself so this was the last remaining
holdout of this government as well as a
couple of adjoining provinces and cities
but all the focus has been on kabul uh
and then at the start of the day we
started to get reports that uh fighters
were not only on the edge of the city
but were actually entering parts of the
city which really did raise the the the
level of an ease the whole tension level
you could it was quite palpable you
could really feel uh that the presence
of the taliban was very close uh and now
uh we have had despite an order earlier
on sunday that taliban fighters should
not go into the city they should hold
back as we heard there they should
be restrained there there have were
reports of looting uh we know that as
soldiers withdrew as some of the police
officers we know actually got rid of
their uniforms and put on civilian
clothes there were reports of various
acts of looting around the city we know
that one university was broken into uh
so that seemed to coincide with this uh
with this move by the taliban to direct
its fighters to actually go into the
city ostensibly to stop the looting
that's at least what they have said to
maintain law and order uh
countermanding it seems their their
earlier order to do so so so that's what
we've seen and in fact on the streets
we have seen now um
where there used to be soldiers where
there used to be police actual uh
taliban figures now taking over taking
over simple duties like directing
traffic or stopping vehicles to do
vehicle checks to check who's inside
where those people are going but very uh
distinctly uh wearing the sort of the
the gab the the the clothing of taliban
uh fighters just where we are here in
kabul just uh behind me this is the
green zone this is a heavily fortified
area of kabul it's blast walls because
it's around here that you have
government offices and embassies and so
on normally you would have lots of army
with humvees mounting a very big
very heavy machine guns they all seem to
have disappeared and instead you have a
taliban on the streets basically taking
over those guard duties okay uh rob as
we're um as you're talking to us we're
continuing to show our viewers these
live and exclusive pictures from
inside the presidential palace
um
there are phones being passed between
the uh between the fighters uh we're
still trying to to get a translation for
you but uh just to get a sense of what's
happening but we are
we are certain now that's confirmed the
taliban are inside
the presidential palace
in kabul
guns on the desks certainly posing there
it seems for
a family photo an announcement of
some kind it will certainly come as a
great shock
uh rob to to many in afghanistan over
the last few weeks people have been
reacting with surprise certainly to the
the speeds of the takeover and that this
seems to be a complete takeover now does
it not uh or the top they're brandishing
now a bullhorn it's uh in order to to
make some kind of
announcement there but this is this is
certainly a takeover we had been hearing
from the taliban earlier that they would
not enter kabul they were wanting a
peaceful
transition of power
how peaceful is it
on the streets of kabul right now
good question uh it it it changes uh by
by the hour here um it has been fairly
uh i can say
there's been a certain tension
throughout the day
we've had reports for example the the
burst of gunfire that was reported
through the u.s embassy with a that
message that u.s citizens should take
shelter now apart from that message we
heard nothing more about that particular
incident uh that got everybody very
excited for a while but then we heard
nothing more about that having said that
just in the last half hour or so in fact
just half an hour about 25 minutes ago
we did hear a series of explosions three
explosions just over behind us towards
the u.s embassy and just as we came on
air in fact there was a force explosion
again in roughly the same direction and
we have at the moment absolutely no idea
what those explosions were if he was
coming from the direction of the embassy
we could only speculate that maybe it
was
something to do with the the evacuation
of the embassy because that's been going
on uh all day here we know that uh parts
of the embassy uh are being cleared out
completely we know that files have been
destroyed there have been fires in there
to destroy uh files and so on um we or
it may have been those explosions to do
with somebody setting explosives from
outside we have been checking social
media as much as we can one of the
problems here is that normally we would
get police reports about these things
but of course
in many respects we don't actually have
a police force at the moment i mean uh
the the
very good question here at the moment is
who actually is in control of kabul um
with the the the taliban ostensibly
taking over and establishing trying to
establish law and order it would seem
that in on the streets at least they
would be
in charge they are the people who are uh
at the corners of the roundabouts
directing traffic etc but there's nobody
actually for us to contact to say what
was that explosion so we are sort of uh
in the dark so to speak um but there
have been so there are troubling signs
as we get into the uh nighttime hours
here of sunday into monday morning it is
slightly uneasy uh there are things
happening that we don't quite know about
and we just have to feel our way uh as
we go uh but it is interesting that the
changes that you have seen on the
streets that um where we once had the
army in their pillar boxes and with
heavy machine guns uh guarding all of
this area which is this green zone which
would which has been traditionally over
many years a real uh target for uh car
bombers for suicide bombers all of those
forces seem to have simply uh melted
away being replaced as i said by a
taliban
people on the streets doing those kind
of duties it's interesting also some of
the other statements coming out of the
taliban this sunday about the change in
direction with ashraf ghanigan we had
been talking about some sort of
transitional government some sort of
change of power
that in theory ashraf ghani was talking
with his his close confidants about what
kind of deal they could propose that
would see a peaceful transition of power
obviously it would not include mr ashraf
ghani being part of that that was always
accepted i think that he could never be
a part of a new government the taliban
would never accept that uh but we had
been expecting that there would be some
sort of form of words that would go to
the negotiators in doha that maybe they
could ratify that might lead to some
sort of transitional
government
or a kind of a caretaker government that
might then call say a lawyer jergo one
of these big gatherings of people being
brought in from all over afghanistan to
discuss the shape and form of a new
government all that seems to have
evaporated very quickly we we now are
left wondering what exactly um what what
type of new government we're facing and
as far as some officials taliban
officials are concerned they are just
talking about a straight handover of
power
why do they need to share power with
anybody that doesn't seem in theory at
least anybody to share power with so
that it seems to be what they are
talking in terms of now is a straight
handover of power and this evening at
least we do seem to be seeing uh that uh
you know in reality uh as a straight uh
physical a grabbing of power if you like
with taliban fighters wandering around
the uh corridors uh of the presidential
palace uh indeed it's it's very talk
hard to to talk about uh
power sharing when we uh
we see the power being held uh
specifically in the hands of those who
are they would who are sitting in the
presidential
uh palace there uh well you've been on
this story all day you've been out on
the streets you've been talking to
people
uh
people have been
clearly very very anxious about the the
rapidly unfolding events uh that have
been happening
uh just as we're we're still trying to
start this translation for you for you
and for our viewers here but just give
us a sense of what people in afghanistan
have been have been saying to you and
the team
as uh these events have been unfolding
yeah there is is a lot of other unease
here about the taliban uh coming back
and taking over i mean it varies from
place to place in the in the the pashtun
stronghold of the south uh of
afghanistan they have a different view
if you like
about the taliban they will view it very
differently in more cosmopolitan areas
such as here in kabul which has been
transformed dramatically in the 20 years
since the taliban were last in power
they will have a very different view
again i mean there have been as ashraf
ghani himself said in his speech just uh
yesterday i think it was that uh there
have been remarkable gains that have
been made in the past two decades or so
and you do see that it is a a very much
more cosmopolitan place that has been
transformed into you've had all of these
influences from abroad people are far
more international have a far more
worldly outlook so there is an awful a
lot of worry concern fear in some in
some cases about having a return of this
regime and you will
meet people of a certain age who do not
have very nice memories at all of when
the taliban was last in charge here from
the mid 90s until 2000 uh 2001.
so there are concerns and yet there is
when we've been talking to people in the
last week or so a gradual acceptance as
they seen the taliban
sweep up these different provinces and
gradually work further towards kabul
itself an acceptance that the the
taliban is coming back in some shape or
form and they have been talking to us
saying well maybe it's okay we could
have some sort of joint government some
power sharing government and of course
all in the last day or so all of that
has changed as we just said i mean uh
it's sharing with whom it doesn't look
like the taliban does have to share with
anyone indeed let me just very quickly
they do have to change they just to jump
in there we're getting more information
out about these live pictures which
we're still uh
broadcasting to our viewers uh for those
watching this on television the the chap
in the suit
uh in the the western style suits uh we
understand he is a palace official
at the afghan presidential palace
and he is saying that this
essentially is
them handing over power
peacefully
to the taliban
so this is the we see a an assorted
taliban fighters there i'm assuming
they're fighters because they're all
brandishing rather large guns
uh but the palace official has just been
speaking on al jazeera saying that this
is now the palace peacefully handing
over power
to the taliban
so this these are the images that we are
showing our viewers now uh certainly
we're still scrambling to get that
translation uh for uh you but it's uh
the very dramatic scenes
uh that we are showing you uh live from
the presidential palace in kabul
uh the palace where of course uh
presidents uh the former presidents uh
ashraf ghani was
beg your pardon i've just been just a
small correction there this was a
handover of the palace and not the power
uh so there's still some confusion this
hour but that palace official was
handing over the palace
to the taliban
handing over the palace to the taliban
so there's still some confusion
about
the
balance of power who is in charge of
afghanistan but certainly with recent
events unfolding the way they have
the chaos continues uh but certainly
very arresting images for you as taliban
fighters and officials speaking
exclusively to al jazeera arabic
we have had the palace official handing
over the presidential palace
to those
taliban fighters
remember of course uh that i think i'm
correct in believing that a few hours
earlier we had a recorded statement from
ashraf hani
who was reassuring afghan civilians that
they would be safe and kabul would not
fall presumably recorded inside the
walls of that palace where we now have
uh i'm being told we have translation uh
let's listen in and hear what's being
said
inside the presidential palace in kabul
you have entered this
are you going to revive the previous
islamic emulator
or are you going to share power with
others as well
our program is
that the commission for the islamic
emirate
they have formed a political committee
which is
engaging with other committees they are
carrying out consultations and leading
to
a good arrangement for the future of
afghanistan
can you
tell us
uh when are your leaders coming to
afghanistan
he's heading the political commission
he's based in qatar
he might come
i'm not fully aware as to when he's
going to come
amirah
when the security is fully insured then
they will also come
foreign
now
okay they've just stopped talking uh for
the moment there's a bit of a delay in
between because we're working with
several different languages here uh
there's a delay between the the
translations but uh the gist of what we
heard they were asking about officials
uh taliban officials who of course have
been negotiating
in doha in qatar
asking
where they are will they be coming back
to afghanistan and
the response there was that once the
security
is fully
assured than those taliban officials who
have been doing the negotiating
over uh several
weeks and months they will be coming
back uh
to
afghanistan just waiting to get to
get more of a
a sense from our translators
as to what's happening for viewers just
joining us now you're watching live
pictures from inside
the uh uh the afghan presidential palace
in kabul
remarkable scenes
really
we had a handover earlier from a palace
official
who was in a western suits
and shorter here he was handing over the
palace
to
the taliban
who are
speaking exclusively with al jazeera
right now
which is trying to to sort out another
translation for you
let's uh just check back in with rob
mcbride
uh he is uh
he's live for us from cabo from the
bureau
rob these pictures are fairly
astonishing uh given the situation
uh that you've been covering over the
last several uh
several days uh in afghanistan just uh
talk us through what what this means the
fact that the the presidential palace
is now uh
is now the seat of the the taliban it
looks like
i mean it is pretty extraordinary well
one thing you have to say
with the taliban is uh their grip on uh
media and social media and we've seen
this in the previous weeks as they have
advanced steadily around the different
provinces around afghanistan they have
been very good uh
very quick at uploading clips and very
very very deft at that of the use of
social media and one of the things you
see constantly you keep on getting mixed
up of which provincial capital was which
the one that the places they head for is
the governor's residence that's always
seen as the seat of power in all of
these provinces and you uh that's one of
the images you look out for as an
indication of yes okay the the
taliban will often exaggerate their
claims of what they have achieved but
that is one of the the telling
indicators of when they have somebody
with a large weapon sitting behind a
grand desk in what was the former
governor's office so you know they're
very good at that and this is i guess
you know this is uh
this is their ace card that we've seen
all of the governors offices now this
seems to be the president's office uh so
again they're very good at
uploading these images of promoting
these images it's worth pointing out i
mean i think we're we there are
different faces of the taliban and i
think the face of the taliban that we're
seeing here in kabul it is rather
different to the face of the taliban
that we've seen in other parts of of
afghanistan you know there are claims of
of war crimes of atrocities that have
been committed there have been
calls from various bodies human rights
organizations to investigate actions by
the taliban in other parts in maybe more
remote provinces i think we're going to
see a different side to the taliban here
in kabul because they're very much this
is a very much a public a world stage if
you like and they want to show a show to
afghanistan to the people here who are
understandably very nervous about having
the taliban back but also to the wider
international community that this is a
different taliban this is a taliban that
has legitimacy it can be trusted it is
responsible and if this is going to be a
responsible government that can deal
with its neighbors can deal with powers
like china we love like russia and we've
seen envoys from the taliban go to those
uh places that can be accepted by the
international community okay rob
mcbride's there thank you very much
indeed we're back into the presidential
palace let's uh listen in we've got a
microphone fitted now and we have
translation let's listen in
oppressing
our people for 20 years
thanks god
i was in guantanamo for eight years
now
okay just uh bring you a couple of lines
while we're waiting for the the the um
we're having some audio issues we're
waiting nothing's being said right now
so we're pausing the translation there
but we have heard from uh cardi
salahuddin a central security official
of the taliban who said they they're
happy because there has been no
bloodshed
the arrangement for the leadership of
the taliban uh to come to uh they're
arranging for the leadership of the
taliban to come to afghanistan
finalizing those security concerns to
bring them back to
afghanistan and also pointing out that
the handing over of the government
headquarters in several provinces around
the country was done in a very peaceful
manner underlining uh that this uh
transition that we're watching right now
is also being done
in a peaceful manner
so
let's uh
let's get some reaction to this now uh
we're joined now on algebra we're going
to see on these pictures but i'm joined
now by umar samad
he's the former afghan ambassador he was
also an adviser to
the former
to abdullah abdullah one of the senior
officials
of the afghan
uh he's speaking to us from
washington d.c it's good to have you
with us uh here on the al jazeera news
hour
just watching these pictures uh that
we're broadcasting live from the
presidential palace
what do you make of this
well it's uh
stunning
it's
it's something that in some ways is
historic after 20 years
the taliban
are back and
and
as though
they had not left even though these were
very long 20 years a lot of bloodshed 9
11 took place
and thereafter uh they they were ousted
and
there's been a war going on for 20 years
billions and trillions of dollars were
spent tens of thousands of people have
died
so um i think
obviously it depends on your politics
but it's a better sweet moment depending
on who you are
we hope that for afghanistan it turns
out to be
a opportunity
to
[Music]
get back
into a normal
and become a normal peaceful country a
country that has seen 43 years of war
and now needs some level of peace and
stability now whether the taliban can
bring this
uh is doubtful they would have to do it
with the help of the afghan people and
all other political and social factions
in the country i don't think one single
group can do that they have to respect
the will of the people in so many ways
and um and hopefully instead of uh
you know becoming a
in
a a you know is sort of an opposition to
the gains of the last 20 years that they
can
build on that
and help the afghan people
move towards a
healing process
we've just uh heard about the
afghan president ashraf ghani has just
published a facebook post
saying that
he left the country in order to avoid
bloodshed so we are hearing now from
ashraf hani who at one time was sitting
behind
that desk in the presidential palace
now
being occupied by several taliban
fighters
we're still on these uh exclusive
pictures out of the presidential palace
uh omar samad's
the taliban
we've heard have played a very savvy
social media game they've also been very
keen to get the message across
that
they are respecting the they want to
respect the rights of
of the afghan people
uh they want to
protect
women uh protect schools uh
basically showing a very different
uh
a different face to what people might
associate with the taliban
uh of 2001 and 2002 and so on are you
are you reassured by these
um
these promises uh that the taliban have
been issuing
over the last uh over the last hours and
days
well uh you know the proof is in the
pudding so it really depends on their
behavior and on their actions and
ultimately their policies er you know
it's it's one thing to to make those
pledges uh at this stage it's another
thing then to
actually execute and implement those i
think it's very it's going to be
a big test for the taliban to to prove
to the rest of the world and prove to
the afghan people that they have changed
they are not the taliban of the 1990s
that they mean
well that they actually care about the
african people that they care about men
and women and girls going to school that
they care about the youth that make up
80 of the country that they care about
the afghan economy
and security and stability and all of
that you know we do know that the
taliban for example
have a harsh justice system but it has
to be used judiciously and has to be
used you know within a certain framework
that people can uh adhere to and at the
end of the day i think they need to also
respect some of the freedoms and
liberties that afghans deserve as
muslims as well as citizens of that
country like they the the freedom to
express themselves the freedom to move
uh so all of that is very important and
it's a big test for the taliban uh yes
we have heard those narratives we just
need to see how it's going to translate
into action it's so it's a test for the
taliban but
thinking of the people of afghanistan
right now who may well be watching these
images
they were uh assured they would be safe
by ashraf hani who has now left the
country
what what next for for the afghan people
especially those women and girls who
might worry uh that
they might not be able to go back to
school or go back to work
see the the first test is uh to see if
the taliban are actually
amenable to a political settlement that
includes that is inclusive and that is
broad-based
if they are then that is the beginning
of um a flexibility and compromise that
they can show on in other areas such as
women's rights and girls going to school
and universities they have come out in
the past few days in different provinces
of afghanistan and also in kabul saying
girls can go to school and they can go
to higher to higher educational
institutions they can work women can
work they have said it but we now need
that as i said to be translated into
policy but the first challenge is going
to be how to create this transition this
interim period is it going to be a
purely tolerable period or is it going
to be a broad-based
power sharing arrangement that others
can also feel they are part of and if
the taliban are smart and they have
learned the lessons of history i think
that they would they're better served
having a broad-based inclusive system
rather than the rigid taliban system
okay omar samad great to get your
thoughts thank you so much for joining
us uh here on the al jazeera newshour
omar samad former afghan ambassador and
adviser to uh top official abdullah
abdullah
thank you very much indeed uh well let's
uh bring in our diplomatic editor james
baze now uh he was reporting from kabul
until last week and joins us now from
un headquarters in new york we'll talk
about the u.n in just a moment james but
uh
our viewers are still being shown these
these images from
inside the presidential palace in kabul
uh these are arresting images are there
not
i mean for someone like me who's been
reporting from afghanistan for 20 years
now um i was there before
the taliban
fell in 2001 uh before the american
special forces arrived on the ground in
afghanistan and just one reaction wow
i mean
to see
the taliban and these are actually
fighting taliban they're not taliban
leadership
these are fight taliban fighters they're
in the presidential palace sitting in
the president's desk some of them
lounging elsewhere in the office in the
armchairs where president ghani used to
meet other world leaders and dignitaries
these are amazing scenes i'm told
elsewhere in kabul elsewhere outside the
presidential palace they are now flying
the taliban flag this has happened so
fast as you say i was in afghanistan
just eight days ago i certainly wouldn't
have left if i knew things were going to
move this fast and it is really quite
amazing after uh the whole 20-year
investment of the west in afghanistan
just the u.s alone spent
144 billion dollars that's from a u.s
government report in afghanistan and for
what there'll be questions asked about
the failures here forget about whether
it was right or wrong to withdraw the us
troops the way it was done was there a
massive intelligence failure did the us
not predict the taliban would move so
fast was there a massive military
failure because remember the u.s
military trained the afghan forces
what did they not understand about that
i think it was the psychological blow of
the announcement of the pull out the
fact the afghan government had made no
preparations uh for the pull out the
fact the u s system with the afghans
effectively uh the uh u.s military were
the officers and the afghans were the
soldiers and when the officers pulled
out uh the soldiers didn't know what to
do i also think uh the us was still
looking at a map of afghanistan that was
made up of provinces and districts and
of course the taliban were looking at a
tribal map and speaking to all the key
tribal players and getting them to to
change sides and lastly what a
diplomatic failure all those talks in
doha the u.s strategy in those talks
proved i think to be uh
not the right strategy at all
they took the taliban on trust that the
taliban once they pulled out their
forces would negotiate with um with the
afghan government that they come up with
a unity government i don't think that
president trump who started those
negotiations or president biden were
perhaps following the words uh that we
used to hear from ronald reagan that
russian proverb he used to um he used to
always cite trust but verify
well well quotes well the the the
diplomatic fallout will be felt far and
wide you had the u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken on the american
television earlier uh claiming that
they've
accomplished absolutely everything they
had to uh this was not a failure of any
shape or form it'd be interesting to see
if he stands by those remarks given the
scenes that we're broadcasting here on
al jazeera just in terms of where the un
stands on this james
we understand that the un security
council
are likely to be meeting to discuss this
it looks like they're going to have an
awful lot to talk about isn't there
absolutely the situation is moving so
fast there was a call earlier on for a
security council meeting some council
members i think have been slightly
dragging their feet because they really
don't know what's going on and they're
trying to find more information
of exactly what the situation is so that
they can have a proper discussion of it
uh the latest information is the
security council meet in just under 12
hours from now that'll be an open
meeting so you can guarantee we'll be
broadcasting it here on al jazeera and
i'm hearing that the representative of
the un in kabul deborah lyons will be
briefing but so will the un secretary
general because of the gravity of the
situation the latest word on the ground
from the u.n is that they are not
evacuating people at this stage
they are not doing any operations though
all un staff confined to their compound
means no humanitarian work is going on
they are desperately worried about the
security situation as are many of these
diplomatic missions which are now
scrambling to get their personnel out of
afghanistan remember out of the 15
security council members six of those
countries were actually countries that
had at some point or other soldiers in
afghanistan and of course some of them
particularly the u.s and the uk
had very large numbers of soldiers uh in
afghanistan uh we've seen pictures in
the last couple of hours the french
ambassador um already evacuated there
are reports that the u.s ambassador has
also now left kabul we don't have that
confirmed at this stage okay certainly
things are moving very very fast in
deeds james bay is the following events
live from the united nations in new york
thank you very much you never know james
you may find yourself on a plane back to
afghanistan at this street but uh thank
you very much indeed uh for bringing us
that update from new york uh let's take
you back to kabul but we're still
showing our viewers uh those exclusive
pictures from inside
uh the presidential palace
where al jazeera has been
live inside
the palace with taliban fighters
have been
have been speaking to our colleagues on
al jazeera arabic
we have also heard from
certainly a palace official who was
handing over the palace control of the
palace uh to those taliban fighters
rob mcbride you've been uh you've been
following developments in afghanistan
well in kabul really uh all day the day
started with the stunning footage of
the stunning footage of diplomats being
airlifted out of the u.s embassy in
kabul seems reminiscent of those
uh
of those uh the the the last chop ride
of saigon
i i just couldn't stop that what we're
showing you our viewers now uh robert's
images of the afghan flag being taken
down
and that is taliban fighters have taken
down
the flag of afghanistan
inside
the presidential palace
that flag has been rolled up
and has been placed on a mantelpiece
uh placed on a mantle piece uh we're
doing a little show-and-tell from one of
our colleagues there
but that's the afghan flag inside the
presidential palace
has come down uh
staggering stuff rob um
as i say the day started with uh those
fairly uh surprising
images and the day in kabul appears to
be ending with images of a
similar
shocking and surprising quality
that's right it is incredible that these
two
things are happening also almost
nintendo or parallel if you like we're
getting everything that's happening
inside the presidential palace and not
far away we're still having the
continuing helicopters coming in and out
of the u.s embassy as you mentioned they
have been continuing since the uh since
the start of day in fact since last
night uh you could hear the helicopters
starting uh to work and that has
continued throughout the day and that
seems to be going on uh
oblivious to what's happening in the
presidential palace uh obviously the
united states is not oblivious but it's
simply concentrating on this one task it
is getting people uh from the from the
embassy or from the embassy compound
over to hamid karzai international
airport to the part of the airport which
uh it's largely cut off from uh from the
outside world and the us would like to
keep it that way we're putting people on
planes and
getting them out oh rob i'm going to cut
you off there because we have now
secured translation there let's listen
in and hear what's going on inside the
presidential palace
quarter past 12
when he is having lunch together with
the officials
[Music]
this is a piece of paper
of the
agenda of what is going to happen during
aid
[Music]
uh
okay
this is uh sufficient for now
so
things are moving very very very very
fast of course anyone following events
uh throughout the day will will have
known the things have been moving very
fast uh very unpredictable
uh what we've just been watching is that
that's uh one of our colleagues from al
jazeera arabic who is inside the uh
presidential palace uh with those uh
taliban fighters uh basically doing a
show-and-tell uh for our viewers
in arabic
so after that flag had been taken down
the flag of afghanistan inside the
afghan at presidential palace
we
have been showing you some of the
objects inside that room we now have one
of the fighters
on the phone uh clearly uh
discussing those uh monumental events uh
this is the taliban of course very
viewers just joining us uh who are
inside the
presidential palace in kabul
one of the officials of the palace uh
has officially handed the palace over to
those
taliban fighters
there's a lot of
chaos and confusion going on right now
but certainly those fighters are are
taking our colleague and uh cameraman
throughout
uh the palace uh heading down
some stairs there
rob you're following these images for us
as well
uh
we're we're getting a tour
it would appear of the the afghan
presidential palace
uh
astonishing footage really a very grand
building we're getting the tour of
inside the presidential palace of course
the afghan president uh ashraf khani
no longer there
but he has
managed to to communicate via facebook
saying that he has
fled to
he left kabul rather to avoid the
bloodsheds uh
how do you think that message will be
received by the people of kabul and the
people of afghanistan who were assured
by him yeah i mean i mean we're already
getting some reaction to ashraf ghani's
departure i mean we're getting and it is
not very complementary i mean dr
abdullah abdullah seen
largely as his adversary in the afghan
government he said that uh uh the that
ghani left her people in a bad position
god will make him accountable but
ultimately will judge him it seems uh we
had the defense minister of ghani's
government saying that he tied the hands
behind the back of the people and sold
the homeland that is not very uh
complementary so
they we're already having some reaction
to ghani's departure um
if
i just wanted to point to to one thing
that james bay said earlier about the un
compound they're being locked down u.n
people just told to stay indoors the un
as we've reported
quite a bit over the past week or so is
desperate to try to put into place
various humanitarian programs and get
out there and do its job but it can only
do that when it has a certain level of
stability well you know that is now on
this taliban administration whatever it
looks like because it seems as though
they have uh by hooker by crook they
have inherited power here that is now on
them to achieve it's up to them to
achieve stability um it's also you know
they also now own this humanitarian
problem which arguably they have helped
to contribute to all the thousands of
people who have been pouring into kabul
trying to escape fighting in other parts
of the country so that also comes with a
taking power with it's not just taking
down the flag it's putting up your own
flag and then taking on the
responsibilities that go along with that
okay rob mcbride there uh with us
following that continuing coverage uh
thank you very much indeed